in this problem a given horizontal
confined aquafer is comprised of four
layers containing the properties given
below the total transmissivity is
1,000 ft squared per day what is the
hydraulic conductivity in layer 2 in
feet per
day so this problem is very easy and can
be solved in only a few
steps so if we look at the civil
engineering reference manual version 1.2
and we search for aquafer we can find in
chapter 6 a section on confined
aquafers so on page
427 aquafer transmissivity is given as t
equal K *
B
in feet squar per second what's given
here is actually feet squared per day
but we can use that too as long as we
remain consistent throughout the
problem on the next page of the
reference manual there's a section
titled multiple aquafer layers here and
Elsewhere on these two pages we can find
that K is the hydraulic conductivity per
unit
width and we can find that b is the
individual layer
thickness so we have been given the
total transmissivity so all we have to
do is subtract the transmissivity of the
known layer to isolate the unknown layer
then divide by the layer thickness to
find the hydraulic
conductivity so let's get
started step one is to solve for the
transmissivity of each individual layer
so we
have a 10t thickness
times
45 feet per
day and that will give us 450
ft squared per
day Layer Two is our
unknown so we
have 20 ft time x and we don't have the
known
yet then we have for layer
three 40 ft Time 5 ft per
day equals 200
100 fet squared per day and then finally
we have 80
ft time
0.6 feet per
day this gives
us
48 fet
squared per
day so
next we have
our subtraction so we
have
1,00 feet squared per
day minus the sum of 1 3 and 4
so 450
+ 200
+
48 ft squar
per day and this gives
us
302t squared per
day finally with step three all we have
to do is divide
302 feet squared per day by the unit
thickness
of the second layer so 20
ft and that will give us an answer of
15.1 ft per
day so that would be the number over
here which we can see is the third
answer to our
left and that's all it takes to solve
this
problem so this problem could have also
asked you to find the equivalent
hydraulic conductivity of the whole area
this equation is also present in the
reference manual on page 428 so as
always always I think it makes sense to
familiarize yourself with the entire
section while you're studying and not
just use the equations that you find
when you're solving the problems see
what else is in there and try to ask
yourself what other things the test
could throw at you instead